how did the ideas of karl marx lead to
stalinism so this particular
implementation yeah
um
is there something fundamental to these
ideas that leads to a dictator and that
leads to atrocities there's something
about the mechanism of the bureaucracy
that's built that leads to
a human being that's able to
attain
integrate
uh absolute power and then start abusing
that power all that kind of stuff like
some of the history of the 20th century
is that
inextricably connected to the ideas of
karl marx i think to some extent it is
but i'm going to also say that if it
hadn't been for the bolsheviks
interpreting marx and saying we can
reach socialism without going through
capitalism
then
it might not have happened
so if you look at the like the
mensheviks were a rival
political group in russia
and that's where heiman minsky who's a
huge inspiration for me so he's an
economist who was maybe can we take a
little attention who was haiman minsky
yeah haiman minsky uh was the person who
developed
a analysis of capitalism based on
financial instability
and he was actually the
phd student of joseph schrompeter
and
an austrian economist as well whose name
i've forgotten temporarily
and he
asked him his parents were
both refugees from russia
during the stalinist period
because the mensheviks were being wiped
out uh in russia just like any other
opponents to
uh the bolsheviks were being eliminated
so i think his parents met in chicago
still remain socialist still remain
politically active
and
he was educated in a family that was
just
imbued with marx as his vision
he and ended up fighting in the second
world war
on the american side
coming back to america and studying
mathematics
and then also doing an economics degree
leading to a phd
and the question he posed for himself is
what causes great depressions
and he put it beautifully said can it
happen again it being the great
depression and if it can't happen then
what has changed between the society
before the first second world war and
after that makes a depression impossible
what's the answer to those two questions
can it happen his answer was yes it can
happen again
but what has prevented happening by the
time he started writing about it which
was the
um late 50s
to the
mid mid 80s late 80s we met once but
only once
a beer
over a beer no he gave a seminar at new
south uni
and a bit of an obstructionist bastard
was
it means argumentative and and likely to
dismiss you so like a good mate of mine
was the guy who brought him out to
australia got a guy called graham white
we're still good hey graeme we're still
good mates g'day graham i love your
language and your accent it's a great
actually there's a there's a really good
tick tock i saw earlier today with an
aboriginal guy saying he loves the
australian language because it's
absolutely ironic and as you're asking
australian a question and he'll give you
an answer which is the opposite of what
he means and you've got to work out the
rest of yourself yeah this he goes up to
another aboriginal mate and says uh
g'day mate how are you doing oh not bad
what have you been doing recently well
not much
uh when are we going so not not not too
far not too soon yeah whereas they're
not too far away
all negatives and he's a beautiful
beautiful rendition yeah yeah that's the
cool thing about the internet culture
they appreciate that ironic side like
for example the best compliment you can
give as an aboriginal
to somebody else's that's deadly
that's deadly that's a compliment it's
deadly okay yeah i wanted another mate
of mine this comes the australian
language if i call you a bastard that's
a compliment yeah depending on how i
intimate the word bastard
bastard
bastard that's deadly yeah i love that
and there's something unfortunately
there's something about the british
accent that makes people sound
maybe brilliant maybe sophisticated uh
but actually
yeah
now that's unfortunately the downside of
that yes you can sound pompous
there's something about
the australian accent that you just
can't sound brilliant
[Laughter]
it humbles you you sound like you're
having a lot of fun there's wit there's
all that yeah stuff yeah but you just
can't be like carl you know karl marx in
an australian accent would just not come
off that is a very good point you would
not be able to pull off the beer yeah i
mean i just yeah it's fascinating that
the accent determines
you know
something about the person maybe it's
the chicken and the egg too it drives it
drives the way of the discourse
obviously there's a lot of brilliance
there's a lot of brilliance in your work
yeah but it sounds like you're always
having fun yeah and look this uh
poncho's got a lot of australian mates
here yeah he spent uh what about about
how long in australia
year and a half and he's got all these
mates who replace aussie rules football
in austin you should join them one day
oh well it's actually rough it's a very
creative sport it's much more fun it's
different than rugby oh very rugby is a
little hopeless rugby has two two morons
smashing their bodies against you know
easy now sorry sorry we did not mean to
offend the rugby fans in the audience
well okay what's so it's too simplistic
it's too simplistic it's it's it's i
mean there's skill in it i've seen some
really skillful rugby union and rugby
league players in my day yeah but it
fundamentally if you hit somebody hard
enough they go down yeah okay whereas in
aussie rules it's about catching the
ball
and then kicking the ball and skill more
skill and it is it's it's a and the
bodies of the athletes uh i can actually
get off me measure what a sport is like
by the bodies it creates and you get
these incredibly elegant
uh life muscular forms out of aussie
rules such beautiful words you have in
your vocabulary life i don't even know
but i'll i'll
i'll assume you know what it means and
maybe somebody in the audience okay so
all right fine fine we should also
mention that you've in your youth
uh you know like like last year have had
uh olympic weightlifting yeah that's
part of your life so yeah long time ago
and like you said tennis i also played
tennis for many many many many years
okay
yeah but so it's a fascinating game it's
a wonderful game yeah that's my favorite
game
karl marx and stalin
yeah so how how do we get onto aussie
football australian and the accent i'm
not really sure you talked about um the
way i said something about karl marx and
with karl marx anyway we got there yeah
we got there but now we return but back
to marx i think it's not the destination
i think mark's
the failure of socialism with diana's
corner captured beautifully this idea
what he called demand constrained versus
resource-constrained economies
and
capitalism is demand constrained okay
and and this is again where neoclassical
theory is completely wrong empirically
completely wrong so the neoclassicals
have a vision of capitalism being
resource constrained and it's about
maximizing your usage of resources
subject to constraints and as corno said
that's really what happened to socialism
what happens under capitalism is that
you have
15 20 companies producing automobiles
they are all trying to capture as much
of the market as they can if you add up
their marketing plans you're going to
get 120 130
of the actual market so they're all
going to have excess capacity when you
build a factory you're building it with
a plan for it to exist for 5 10 15 years
you have to have excess capacity in the
factory so that means that capitalism
has a far greater productive capacity
than it actually uses and then the way
that you manage to get demand into your
factory is to innovate and produce
something nobody else does or you're
producing in volume and when somebody
produces like a bung tire comes out of
firestone then goodyear is ready to
expand its production and take advantage
of that so that's that's the actual
nature of competition in capitalism and
that means that we get a cornucopia as
of goods even if we're lowly workers the
variety of goods in capitalism is
overwhelming
and and that's just doesn't happen in
socialism you get your 1942 cossack as
your motorbike that's it when you put
your money down to buy a refrigerator
it'll arrive in 10 years
because the factory is already fully
constrained
so all these resource constraints mean
that people aren't happy
under socialism
and if you've got a whole bunch of
people
that aren't happy
then the best way to control them is to
suppress them
so i think in that sense ultimately yes
it does lead to something like stalinism
so it's easier to give happy people
freedom
yeah i mean happy people get pretty
silly outside i'm not not particularly
the the extent to which americans
overuse and distort the word freedom
drives me by me um well but you know the
all of these words can be distorted but
they all at the core have some
fundamental power and beauty and then we
just distort on the surface for the fun
of it yeah just start battles on twitter
and so on but what citizens of the
soviet world didn't feel was freedom
yeah not just in first of all it wasn't
freedom to buy commodities the
commodities are supposed to be on the
shops weren't there
uh the volume couldn't be produced and
what you then got out of that as well
was the you know the classic soviet joke
they pretend to pay us and we pretend to
work
okay
so you're not motivated oh the guy i
went to cuba about uh eight years ago
yep invited to give a talk there and are
staying in a hotel itself the hotel's a
story
there's one day my meetings were
cancelled so i thought i might go down
to the beach and they had a in the in
the hotel they had a wing which is the
tourist office and there were three
women working inside the office so i
thought i'd just go up and ask them you
know how do i get to the beach and one
of them says to me i stood there just
stood in the
in the room
waiting to see if they'd make eye
contact with me three women nobody else
in the place none of them looked at me
so i finally went up to one of them and
said i want to go to the beach and do
some surfing work said i can get a taxi
outside
now fundamentally she issues saying i'm
being paid [ __ ] money here
i'm not gonna i don't want to work
uh i'm not gonna do
anything
uh apart from sit here and qualify for
my time
and as much as there are reasons the
cubans have suffered from american
embargoes and all that sort of stuff
you've still got that fundamental
shortage economy that uh the corn i
spoke about coming out of the structure
of central ownership and central control
of distribution and investment based my
heart because i think some of the
effects of that
persist throughout time
it become part of the culture too yeah
yeah
it's very negative culture yeah yeah
well from
from the western perspective well even
from the people living through it i mean
like i had enough conversation with
cubans you know meeting him on the
street hopping in a cab
does one guy was talking to was a he was
an industrial chemist and he got a bit
of money being a cab driver because he
could make money out of taking foreign
tourists from the airport to the city
you